nochmals glück hat meine lieben freunde
ihr seht es leider schon links neben mir
und zwar zusammen
tennis wieder am start das t shirt was
ich gerade habe gibt es ab dem ersten
zwölf neuen luca shop und dort gibt es
dann auch auf dem ersten zwölf genau
limitiert dazu allerdings in einem
anderen video mehr denn meine damen und
herren sondern ich habe es heute hier
zusammengefunden und mal wieder auf eine
hilfe folge zu reagieren
wie jedes mal dieselbe scheiße los
geht's let's go ist das wirklich ein
aufnahmeritual davon habe ich nichts
wenn man so bauarbeiter ist und nicht
nur bearbeitet werden wenn wir deine
füße einmal ein betonieren dürfen
[Musik]
er war doch kein beton
das ist einfach erde
wir gehen jetzt oder erhalten sollen und
hieraus bei unglaublichen beginnen soll
ich habe ich die schnauze voll und dann
noch so eine scheiße ich habe die
schnauze voll lesen zu seine freunde ja
egal wer das war
dass das nebensache ich kann es ja nicht
so eine sache
doch seine füße da ein bisschen hier
kann ja nicht sagen
außerdem war ich immer schon in lahr ein
verknallt in der schule roxanna sagte
direkt dass seine freundin klage gar
keine ahnung alter
juni werden sich der genesene horst so
peter ja das hat sie gerade gesagt also
nicht verstanden der bauarbeiter der
macht so arbeitet sofort acht uhr
morgens ist so 16 uhr danach ein
feierabendbierchen so richtig geil
einfach so stechen gegen fall auch mal
an dem vor
ich muss sagen arbeitest du mich auch
von 8 bis 16 uhr in hast du nach dem
feierabend bieten ja also heißt du quasi
auch gummi ja abonniert alessandra sie
heißt 11 juni ganz locker mal peter man
nennt ihn nicht umsonst als mieter also
mal schauen wie presslufthammer peter
den danny vielleicht befreien kann
alles ist alles okay er sagt in die
jahreszeit ist alles okay macht euch
keine sorgen das war ehrensache
du musst mich regeln ist scheiße aber
wanderer ich fühle mich schon manchmal
ziemlich gleich zu beginn direkt
das kann ich nicht das ist ehrensache
das kann ich nicht machen die ja
immerhin schon die sache hier oben kam
der umfrage musst du schon mal eine
mutprobe ablegen ja nie was ist legal
aber nicht alter sagen wir nein frau die
meisten warten und schauen was ist das
da bist du denn damit freunden die sagen
mutig bis bach models und dann denkt man
sich ja nicht kaufen
er ist an sich die befreundete das ist
ja keine mutprobe
es ist ja nein das erste oder form von
feinschnitt so sein wie dein vater ich
verschossen inhalt ist sauer wenn du
denkst dass das die letzte probe was ich
immer geschnitten aber dort mit aber
noch einige folgen der wagen mit seinem
bild die ganze zeit doch ich will
einfach nur noch bauarbeiter werden egal
ist das leben der betrieb wird selbst in
der sie tätig werden und wird sagen luca
wir machen jetzt mal eine filiale in
ihren alten und jetzt mit anderen see
geschmissen ist die kiste mit
instrumenten wie müsste einmal bitte bei
uns ins fahrzeug gelagert werden dann
nimmst du dir diese eisenstangen
komplett einmal bitte komplett ans
andere ende der baustelle also denn je
so der die ganze [ __ ] abhalten für
helme im glas praxis auto dann nimmst du
alle eisenstangen von diesen zehn
milliarden stück und trixi ans andere
ende der baustelle ich trinke mit noch
ein und dann
[Musik]
ja
erstmals fand die alle ab in operetten
los man sieht doch schon dass da
irgendwas passiert
jetzt kommt er da und sagt seinen
freunden hier
wenn jemand mit ihr komme eine halbe
stunde laufen floh der mann hat zwei
gründe der parteien die wände bilden
neue mutprobe neue aufgabe und zwar am
steigt jetzt in den bagger holst für uns
vom metzger 20 brötchen aber noch nicht
mal ein führerschein ist doch scheißegal
man das ist egal ob über 3.000 stellen
war zurück
die sagen einfach das alles mutprobe ist
machen wir unsere arbeit mutprobe
erholungs mal frech und mutproben aber
es muss aber man muss ja sagen das hat
er in sachen alles alles alles
ehrensache also wir machen wirklich mit
jedem neuling quads ohne derbe mutprobe
aber dieser danny der ist speziell der
bekommt von unseren richtige
spezialbehandlung zu sagen
spezialbehandlung ort war stegers hatte
auch seinen helm falsch rum
[Musik]
hauptsache er hat sein handy quer
gehalten gefilmt und das video gerade
war hochkant egal weitergeht hilft ihr
neues bescheid
das ist einfach hilft mir dass sein
nachhilfe mir eine komplette scheiße ja
es ist alles fällt es ist alles nur
gespielt in dem sich die dümmsten themen
raus eigentlich geht diese serie auch
darum dass man jung pleite und
verzweifelt ist keiner jungen es ist
keiner verzweifelt und es ist keiner
pleite na denn ist schon jung ja bei mir
nicht ja aber mit pleite das wird könnt
ihr streichen junge und verzweifelt da
wird es doch schon so ein bisschen also
zwei drittel vom titel haben wir diesen
filter den fehlt der knospe im gehirn
869 klick gemacht bei denen gehirn was
für eine knospe ja da gibt es eine
knospe die hat bei die augen nicht ganz
klick gemacht
deswegen sind ihre rolle so dumm
weisheit ist jahrhunderts leute ich war
es euch nicht des herrn gegen das war
das auto verbitterter seinerzeit peter
lustig ist ja auf jeden fall als nicht
mehr
die wohl mal hoop scheffer dann doch
nicht
die irgendwie gerade so kannst du dein
vater sein ja ich dachte auch dass die
damit diesem peter meinen aber
anscheinend ist der vater doch auch
einer den die anderen kennen aber jetzt
ruft da erstmal die polizei an
aber so wie ich hilf mir kenne kommt die
polizei sowieso und dann kommt die
polizei nicht weil die das für viel geld
gekostet schätzte die polizei
ja sagt nicht mein tag heute nach dem
unfall wird es mehr fragen weil es gut
ist ja alles okay
was für eine unterhaltung der gal yam er
tut ja auch nicht dabei er steht ja auf
die dann würde ich jedoch gegenüber so
und er ist so der letzte tropfen elend
was noch in deutschland geblieben ist
ich wollte eigentlich klar als etwas
trinken gehen warum warum du musst erst
mal jede schöne nachtschicht schieben
richtiger wollen wenn man nichts sieht
alter oder was der ganz anderer jetzt
baustellen
mit lara mein gott habe ich keinen bock
mehr und er geht am liebsten mike o mein
gott noch dass dessen flacher kaputt wer
weiß was noch mit den beiden noch und er
muss es ja auch was
na klar ein like unter dem video sein
mitleid für danny anderer stelle fand
ich das heute wieder das allerdings auch
beendet meine lieben freunde wenn euch
diese hilfsaktion von uns mal wieder
gefallen hat dann doch nicht einen
daumen hoch unter die video hier daher
schlagen wir als laserdrucker weiß ich
es mir den geist aus deutschland
[Musik]